[Music]
not a big coffee person I'm not don't
drink coffee I run on anxiety yeah
that's right free clean-burning internal
cocaine you make yourself nothing gets
my heart beating faster than when I wake
up and I'm just like oh they gonna get
me helps me out a lot
I'm just not one of those guys if I
drink coffee it makes me really really
punchy just like a little bit people
will be like you're like my dog excuse
me Peter Peter put down the coffee tell
me your thoughts on my dog I'm over here
like I'm diffusing a bomb it's all PD
Adam macchiato I mean I get it I want to
like coffee it smells great gives you
something to do first thing in the
morning I then scratch and pick and
question major life choices was Deanna
right for me
that's gonna be a gif online coffee is
also a completely acceptable reason to
leave work that's a nice little bonus
people that drink coffee always going
around the office like going on run
going on run gonna leave 30 30 45
minutes or going on copy of it we could
drink the coffee in the kitchen we don't
want the kitchen coffee for coffee
people I'm gonna go get coffee coffee
coming look I don't want coffee so I
don't get to go I'm stuck back at the
office with my water and the weird
creepy tea lady it's like I'm drowning
herbs have I told you about my cat but
even coffee people can admit that
coffees not the best tasting drink in
the world I mean how good can it taste
if you got to mix it with three pumps of
caramel a quart of cream and chase it
with a Cinnabon you know I mean that's
just a coffee milkshake drinking one of
those because you like coffee
it's like eating an apple pie because
you're like an apple a day think about
it and listen I know there are real
coffee drinkers out there people that
drink real coffee sipping black hot
espresso just like mmm this tastes like
asphalt
and the cremated ashes of a group of
Uruk I've big discussion as to whether
or not or ook I would hit guess who
pushed for it
a lot of people at home googling it I
want in on the fun
plural of Orcs big group okay what is
that clicking is that a problem
sounds like we're doing this by the
fireside I want to tell you the story of
the man with a metal hat now that's all
staying in that looks concerned Spence
ease this is Spencer he's the stage
manager this is all getting on the show
[Applause]
this town dad read not just saying what
I see red this man's name is red what's
that better I was whacking my button the
technical term
sorry everybody the sound problem was I
was masturbating natural way back in so
coffee
I'm gonna be wrong it looks delicious I
want in and I know I know there are real
coffee drinkers out there people that
drink black espresso just like hmm this
tastes like asphalt and the cremated
ashes of a group of old guy big
discussion as to whether or akai would
hit it did
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to like real coffee I want to sit
around a tiny table drinking black water
like sophisticated grown-ups just huh
robust with chocolate overtones
he's his quantum all in but every time I
tried I'm like dirt with dirt overtones
just from that there dirt pile they say
coffees an acquired taste acquired
that's just code which means in six
months this will taste a little bit less
like [ __ ] acquired taste everything is
an acquired taste you could eat a
post-it note every day eventually you'd
acquire a taste for it yeah yeah yeah
yellow is my favorite kind of taste like
strawberry you think yellow would be
like lemon or banana I'm getting
strawberry but I haven't given up I want
to like coffee I'm always trying given
another shot casual day dates brunches
those neutral territory Starbucks
breakups that's when you want coffee you
want to be wide awake for that like tell
me more about my fear of commitment
uh-huh upper limit problems you say
I want to be a coffee person I want to
go to a little neighborhood coffee shop
with the cute sandwich boards out front
with clever messages written in colorful
chalks like miso coffee me latte you
long time that's hilarious I want in the
mind behind that serve me something hot
I want a sip hot tar out of a tiny cup
and pretend I'm a giant won't sir
I want my coffee I like alcohol and
coffee shops are like the bars you get
to go to during the day but instead of
pints of beer you got mugs of coffee set
a whiskey shot espresso shots and
instead of throwing up you have panic
diarrhea somebody checking their nails
while they're talking to you and they
won't stop just like
hey Nick can I talk to you about the
audio issues
[Applause]
[Music]